you have to start a business around
something that you are passionate about
or you're going to fail it's important
to make money and I want you to make a
lot of money and that comes from
starting the business that helps people
and is around something that you love to
do if you're only chasing the dollars
they're not gonna come I'm Evan
Carmichael your friend and all things
entrepreneurship and today I want to
answer a question from one of our
Facebook fans vixen who wrote in to say
I don't know what to do
so vixen wants to start a business thank
you for writing in I feel your pain it's
a common question I get asked and it's
it's a great question to ask because too
many entrepreneurs jump into a business
because they're trying to make a lot of
money and they end up broke and then up
tired and frustrated and wasting all
their energy going down the wrong path
on something that they thought would
help get them rich quick you got to
start a business around something that
you love to do here's how I started mine
this business of helping entrepreneurs I
just sold my company and I got asked to
do some speaking the YMCA asked me to
come and talk to their entrepreneurs say
can you help our young group of
entrepreneurs develop and share your
lessons hey this is great why not I'll
do it and I spent weeks preparing for it
and promoting it and they were promoting
it and the day came I was so excited my
heart was pumping I remember walking
into the door isn't going up to the
elevator and going into the room this
big room full of chairs and my heart
sank for a second and I took a big
swallow because after all that
preparation and all that promotion for
this free event only three people showed
up to this event
three people and it was so sad and so
disappointing because I'm so looking
forward to doing this and I continued on
because there were still three people
and the show must go on
and it was awesome it was so much fun
and I touched those three people that
day I helped them I knew they would go
home different people than when they
came you can see the looks on their
faces as we talked that now they had
renewed energy and hope and ideas of
voices that grow their business and I
knew that I had to continue doing this
even if I couldn't find a way to make a
scale I had to keep doing this this is
what I was born to do and you've got to
find that for yourself
even if it wasn't getting paid to do it
even if I couldn't find a way to make
money even if I had to go find a job to
support myself so I can keep doing this
on the side I had to find a way to keep
doing it and that's when you know you're
on the right path
there's a famous entrepreneur George
Lucas started the Star Wars franchise is
worth over four billion dollars today
and if you read his store and how he got
started he says that his first six years
in business were a failure he didn't
know what he was doing he thought about
giving up he thought about quitting he
thought about going back and getting a
real job to support himself and just
survive his friends and family thought
he was nuts but he kept going he kept
going because he felt he had to because
he loved what he was doing he had a
passion for filmmaking that you can only
understand if you had that same passion
if he didn't love what he was doing so
much he would have quit because it's too
hard but he kept at it and he's worth
over four billion dollars today so
you've got to start a business around
something that you are intensely
passionate about how do you find it my
favourite way as I started to make a
list and I made three different lists
the first list looks at things that
you're really excited about doing what
do you like to do in your day to day
life you know what do you like to do
that helps people so it's not things
like sitting on my couch and watch TV
because that's just a stress outlet you
couldn't do that all day long and be
happy with your life what do you do in
your life that makes you happy that's
your first list then you think about
things that you want to do things you
wish you could do things you wish you
could spend more time on then you write
down those ideas and in the third list
is things that have frustrated you in
the past that you've solved you found
the solution for something that was
really bugging you because it was
buggins new it's probably gonna bug
somebody else and you could probably
help them with it make those three lists
and see what jumps off that page see
what potential business opportunities
there are on there the amount of money
you're gonna make is gonna be directly
related to one how much you love what
you're doing and two how much you're
helping people so you want to look at
that list and think about how much you
love all those ideas and how much you
can use those ideas to help other people
that's the beginning of your opportunity
to find your dream business I have a
worksheet that explains all that and
then the next steps and a lot more deal
detail that you can check out on a
website but the first part really is
finding a business that you are
extremely passionate about and you love
doing that's step number one
all the business advice in the world is
not going to help you unless you've got
that part figured out so good luck
you're asking the right question vixen
you're on the right path and for anybody
in the same situation it's really worth
spending the time to figure that out
before you just jump into any
opportunity because you're probably
gonna go broke and end up frustrated and
angry if you end up into the wrong
business it's a good luck keep us posted
I want to hear about your progress for
those of you watching if you like the
video please give it a thumbs up below
it makes you want to do more for you and
I love to hear we have to think if you
want to leave a comment under the video
I love seeing those and I always
read them so thank you and I'll see you
on the next episode